American researcher Mark Dickey has been
rescued from a cave in southern turkey
after a successful three-day operation
he became trapped more than a thousand
meters underground inside the Walker
cave last Saturday after falling ill 150
Rescuers some of whom were flown in from
neighboring countries worked around the
clock to save him he's now been given a
medical treatment
it is amazing to be above ground again I
was underground for far longer than ever
expected within with an unexpected
medical issue I want to immediately
thank
afad Rajiv shalib the the support of the
Turkish government saved my life
literally no questions asked
joins us live now from Istanbul with
more on this sir Russell this was quite
an extensive rescue operation wasn't it
indeed it was one of the most
complicated rescue operations that
turkey have ever seen so on the second
at the late of August Mark DK started to
dive into the cave to map the cave he's
a researcher as well and then on the 2nd
of September while deep down roughly
more than 1 000 meters his stomach
started to bleed and there was something
wrong his colleagues realized that but
then he was stuck there and the Medical
Aid came one day after that on the 3rd
of September so the rescue Air Force
immediately started however it's quite a
difficult difficult terrain it's quite a
difficult a very deep cave so more than
100 more than 150 Rescuers were involved
in the operation from turkey and from
several European countries The Rescuers
started to to set up the Rope lines deep
down to the the cave and also they have
set up several stages as well to reach
him to take him out and of course since
he was injured they could not take him
straight out at very several stages on a
stretcher he had to stop and have a rest
frequently and then to be taken out so
that's why it took that much long and of
course this is not just a straight down
cave it's also there was vertical
sanctions and with low temperature and
psychologically imagine that it's quite
dark and you stay in there for an
extended period of time and particularly
at the vertical sorry at the horizontal
sanctions so it's wet it's quite cold
and mud and so and so they had to be
very very careful not that he was
already injured and also that's why it
took that much long however now since
last City I mean at a particular and
right after midnight The Rescuers have
been able to came out difficult terrain
there as you say I mean have there been
any questions is raised over whether he
should have been there in the first
place
he's a researcher so they were there for
a cave Expedition so it was a group of
researchers these guys are not only the
cavers but researchers as well they say
they were there for scientific reasons
to map the cave so Mojo came was
discovered quite recently and that's and
and it is it is the length of the cave
is roughly around 4 000 meters wide the
the depth is more than 1 200 meters so
these researchers were there diving
there to map the the cave it is the
third deepest cave in Turkey so they say
the reason that they were there is was
it was scientific and of course is a
very difficult terrain it's on the top
of a Plato and so quite far away from
any civil Center so it takes hours of
driving to reach to that cave so and
that's why now there has been some
criticism but the the teams the cavers
they said they were purely therefore the
scientific reasons
okay rasul said uh thank you very much
indeed